you know already getting started getting
started already
um yeah thank you for coming to our ASMR
tape thank you so much um we hope that
you feel relaxed stimulated we're gonna
start off with with some flowers that we
found registered about
I know it's fall so I brought my witch's
brew absolutely gorgeous
is it vintage it is listen don't forget
about me election brought my
grandmother's urn my auntie I love it it
makes a wonderful sound actually if you
run your finger on the rim have you
voted yeah are you registered to vote
sad is that you Eunice maybe she speaks
a Morse code we also brought some snacks
here don't forget to send your absentee
ballot in did someone say midterm made
some fresh iced tea
I just want to stir that up
we have some seashells here simply
define our last item actually today it's
one of my favorites it's an egg timer
here give it a listen
so comic it takes two minutes to
register you know everything's gonna be
okay and the time it took you to watch
this video you could have Oh a little
ring there oh well we've run out of
items to to share with you we we hope
you enjoyed your time as much as we did
yeah I feel completely satiated relaxed
hmm we wouldn't leave you on that thank
you